bonjour et bienvenue à tous, c'est
le flux d'invités d'inférence active 28.1,
nous sommes le 14 octobre 2022. aujourd'hui, nous allons entendre et
discuter de la rationalité repensée par
Giovanni Rolla, alors Giovanni, merci
beaucoup de vous être
joint à cette présentation et à cette
discussion avec impatience  vous
merci merci alors ce fut un plaisir de
recevoir votre invitation il y a quelques
mois et je suis ravi d'être ici
pour avoir cette opportunité de discuter de mon
travail
euh je vais épargner votre demande
euh notre suggestion je suis euh présenter
ceci  article que j'ai écrit il y a quelques années
et euh alors que nous parlions des coulisses
j'ai j'ai changé d'avis plusieurs
fois et je vais le préciser
lors de la présentation depuis que j'ai
publié cet article mais c'est un
plaisir  néanmoins d'avoir la chance
de présenter cette vidéo ici et euh de la
partager avec le monde donc je suis très
content
euh donc on va parler de
repenser la rationalité et
c'est le c'est l'
itinéraire  Je pensais
vous présenter donc d'abord je
parlerai de rationalité et de
cognition sans contenu, puis je présenterai
mon point de vue que j'ai appelé
rationalité radicalement inactive et mots de sécurité
sur l'agence et l'interaction compétente
et le raisonnement et la rationalité ils sont
proches avec un couple  d'objections la
première étant que
tout ce que je suis présent ici est un vrai
libéral d'une manière excessivement libérale, cela
englobe trop et la deuxième
objection qui, je pense, est celle qui
peut vous intéresser le plus est de savoir si
elle est compatible avec les effets  avec un
processus prédictif dans notre codage prédictif qui
est bien sûr dans l'installation dans le c'est
près des deux voitures au centre pour
faire une influence active
alors
voici le
voici désolé,
mes premières réflexions sur la question sont
que traditionnellement le très
euh orthodoxe  avoir une vue sur la rationalité
euh suppose au mieux de ma connaissance
c'est vraiment comme une hypothèse que la
rationalité doit dans leur raisonnement
que pour inst  ance je crois que B dans une
action a sont rationnels si et seulement s'il
y a le raisonnement qui sous-tend
le Bure donc et bien sûr ce n'est juste pas
n'importe quel raisonnement la question de raisonnement
doit acquérir avec certains certains
repères formels tels que la logique classique
ou le raisonnement probabiliste ou
les heuristiques pour croire et agir
rationnellement selon ce film traditionnel
nécessitent de respecter certaines normes formelles
et cela, comme je l'ai dit, cela me semble être en
grande partie une hypothèse sur ce que
signifie être rationnel pour définir la
rationalité en termes de raisonnement,
donc si la rationalité nécessite un raisonnement
et  si le raisonnement implique l'évaluation
des croyances par rapport à certains repères formels,
alors la rationalité implique un
contenu pour la cognition
où le contenu que je considère comme ayant au minimum des
conditions d'exactitude étant capable
d'avoir
raison ou tort ou dans ou sur une
notion plus importante étant vrai ou faux de sorte que
le  l'idée ici est que la rationalité
passe nécessairement par le contenu elle passe par les
croyances  raisonnement et la comparaison ou
désolé
de mettre à jour en ce moment
une mise à jour logicielle Je suis désolé qu'il y ait eu
une fenêtre contextuelle dans ma fenêtre ici, donc
euh
ce serait, je pense, la
vision standard de la rationalité
et
si c'est ainsi que la rationalité
implique nécessairement  contenu c'est un bon ajustement
avec le cognitivisme classique ou le
cognitivisme en général
qui est l'opinion que la combinaison
implique nécessairement un
contenu représentationnel à tout le moins pour certains
cognitivistes bien sûr cela pourrait impliquer
aussi
euh
un contenu conceptuel mais à tout le
moins un contenu représentationnel qui a
conditions de précision
mais cette vision classique n'est
pas si bonne qu'elle ne correspond pas si bien à la
cognition radicalement inactive et incarnée
que je suis ici euh en pensant pas
spécifiquement au radical et à l'activisme de
Goodwin Maine dans les livres récents mais je
pense que cela défie aussi d'autres  des points de vue
qui ne sont pas présentés comme radicalement et
actifs, mais bien sûr ils partagent certains
locataires fondamentaux avec des radicaux et des actifs  sm
nous pourrions les appeler euh vues radicalement incarnées
des cognitions telles que
euh avec les vues présentées par Ezekiel
Powell ou
la vie modèle sensorielle de Berman, vous avez également
la variété d'inactivisme de Gallagher dans son
livre de 2017 et aussi le Je veux dire la vue
de Tony Kimero dans son  Livre de 2009 sur
la psychologie écologique et les
systèmes dynamiques, ils partagent tous des locataires communs
et me voici, je sais que c'est très
controversé, mais je traite ces
points de vue comme des points de vue radicalement incarnés de la
cognition et je me
concentre spécifiquement sur les points de vue radicaux et actifs de la
cuisson
ils disent tous que la reconnaissance n'est pas
contente représentationnelle ce qui revient en
quelque sorte à dire qu'on peut penser à des
formes basiques de cognition sans
contenu ou à un niveau basique de
reconnaissance sans contenu
qui émerge à travers l'
exploration active de son environnement et au-
delà du radical et de l'activisme par  ce que nous voulons
dire
cela pourrait être cette idée pourrait être
encaissée en termes de maîtrise des engagements moteurs sensoriels
une question de savoir
-comment savoir comment s'engager avec son
entourage au lieu de savoir qu'il
y a tant et tant autour de soi donc
c'est très clairement ce que font Paulo et
ses collègues et euh kimero par exemple
dans leurs livres euh radical et l'activisme
a une certaine tendance à biaiser
engagements de modèles sensoriels schémas de modèles sensoriels
Etc
et euh,
mais les développements récents ont, je pense,
incorporé cela, donc le c'est l'
utilisation de l'essentiel de cette idée,
donc si nous combinons des vues incarnées radicales
de la rumination ou du radical et de l'activisme
et le carburant classique sur  la rationalité
ce que nous avons est quelque chose que l'angle a
décrit comme suit
un activisme est la vision que la cognition
est fondée sur une compréhension rationnelle de la prière
du monde qui est basée
sur l'acquisition sensori-motrice de la
situation de la vie réelle
et il explique ces euh cette idée de
pré-  compréhension rationnelle
par
um
par par les idées de melopentin
Heidegger selon lesquelles le rapport
au monde ne peut être qu'un enracinement dans
p  la pratique des inactifs dans l'action et la
pratique de l'interne est médiatisée par
le corps, donc ce qui semble être implicite
ici, c'est que contrairement à l'action et à la pratique, la
rationalité n'est pas en fait
c'est quelque chose qui n'est pas à un
niveau de combinaison très basique, c'est donc
ce qui s'est passé quand nous nous
faire de la place pour un niveau de base de cognition
enraciné dans l'actif et dans la pratique et le
séparer des niveaux supérieurs de
combinaison qu'ils sont généralement le
lieu le classique chanceux de la rationalité,
donc
l'idée en résumé est que
la cognition controversée ou la cognition de base
qui émerge à travers le sensoriel  les
engagements moteurs ne sont pas rationnels
donc les engagements modernes sensoriels cependant les
vertus prolifiques elles peuvent être ne peuvent pas
être évaluées du point de vue de la
rationalité seul le contenu pour la cognition la
combinaison de haut niveau peut être une
définition rationnelle qui s'exprime par
exemple dans les croyances et récemment
et bien c'est quelque chose  que je
n'ai pas abordé sur le papier mais
c'était ma motivation implicite à d  eal avec
ce sujet
comme quelqu'un qui vient de la philosophie de
l'esprit c'est l'idée du mythe du
donné au moins une version de celui-ci
il me semblait à l'époque et euh j'ai été
persuadé correctement par un critique de ne pas
aborder le sujet  c'était très
alambiqué dans ma présentation initiale
mais il me semble que si nous divisons la
reconnaissance de base d'une pensée
et d'une action rationnelles et que nous ne pointons pas vers
le
puits, il n'y a pas d'intersection
entre ces deux niveaux, il semble que le
radical et l'activisme et  euh des
vues similaires seraient commises sur le mythe
du donné impopularisé par les vendeurs et les
modérations par McDowell comme un problème pour les
champs impérieux de mon esprit
donc il semble que c'est je pense une
[musique]
un problème philosophiquement intéressant
mais ce n'est pas quelque chose qui est  euh sur l'
avant-garde de l'article, c'était ma
motivation implicite ici que d'expliquer
comment pouvons-nous combiner le
niveau de cognition sans contenu ou de base à travers des
engagements sensoriels modernes avec ratio  nalité si
vous ne pouvez pas, il semble qu'il y a une
sorte de donnée qui n'est
pas complètement expliquée dans notre image
de l'esprit, donc c'est quelque chose que je
voulais Je veux toujours essayer d'explorer
cette intuition plus clairement mais je n'ai pas
Je n'ai pas abordé ce sujet euh mais je pense qu'il y a quelque chose dans le
sens de pourquoi ce que je vais montrer
aujourd'hui est je pense que c'est une façon d'épiler
cette accusation d'être engagé
dans le mythe du donné
alors comment pouvons-nous reconcevoir la rationalité je
veux dire  Je pense que pour éviter ce
problème et éviter l'idée que nous avons
deux niveaux complètement séparés l'un de
l'autre où l'un est
le lieu de la rationalité classique et ce qu'il y a d'
autre en dessous, ce n'est pas rationnel, je
pense que l'idée est de rejeter la
rationalité  doit être défini ou cela
implique nécessairement le raisonnement
n'a pas besoin d'être encore conçu mais
alors le défi devient d'offrir une
proposition positive de ce qu'est la rationalité sinon le
raisonnement et voici Susan H  urley dans un
article que ma connaissance est la seule
qui porte
sur ce sujet et je pense qu'elle était
également préoccupée par le mythe du
donné d'ailleurs à l'époque et il est une
longue citation d'ici phenomide moi
lisant c'est que la rationalité  pourrait
émerger d'un système complexe de
relations hiérarchiques centralisées d'
inhibition, de facilitation et de coordination
entre différentes couches horizontales
dont chacune est une rationalité dynamique et environnementale
repensée en
termes horizontaux ou modulaires euh je ne sais pas
si elle doit utiliser cette
terminologie mais  de toute façon c'est comme ça qu'elle a
choisi de l'exprimer c'est durablement
lié à l'environnement ça ne
dépend pas seulement des procédures internes qui font la
médiation entre l'entrée et la sortie comme le
contenu soit pour l'organisme dans son
ensemble ou pour un
module cognitif central délimité verticalement plutôt ça
dépend de  relations complexes entre
un monde dédié impliquant des couches qui
surveillent et répondent à des aspects spécifiques
du n  environnement naturel et social
et du réseau de neurones et réduire
leurs réactions à partir de leurs réponses, c'est
à ma connaissance le premier cas de
quelqu'un travaillant sur l'approche inactive
d'une manière qui
est évidemment plus
généralement associée au travail d'
avano qui est aussi un activiste mais
dans une approche différente du radical et de l'
activisme et voici la plus ancienne
et à ma connaissance avant que j'écrive cet
article, c'est que la proposition la plus claire
de rationalité repensée
dans les termes natifs, mais ce n'est
pas quelque chose qui a eu du succès
après sa publication à  à ma connaissance en
fait je n'ai pas vu grand chose depuis
et pour résumer l'idée c'est qu'il
faut changer le Focus explicatif
qui est la rationalité n'est pas exclusivement
pensée comme un Contenu impliquant la
capacité dans cette proposition elle se situe
ou Monde impliqué dans des mondes augmentés
et s'il est radicalement incarné, cela
dépend de la morphologie et de l'action corporelles
et de la façon dont l'organisme est situé et
agit  s dans cet environnement, l'idée
sera minimalement morte, donc c'est ce que j'appelle la
rationalité radicalement inactive
est euh dans une
définition très vague jusqu'à présent, c'est qu'un Asiatique
agit rationnellement dans la mesure où l'humain
maintient une interaction efficace avec
son environnement en coordonnant ses
capacités cognitives  selon
des conditions environnementales de contraintes
et de stations solides et bien sûr cela
nécessite parfois de s'adapter à
des circonstances imprévues l'
intuition centrale est celle
-ci et il est intéressant de comparer cette
idée de rationalité radicale et active
avec une autre des idées de Susan Hurley dans
un texte de 2003 qu'elle  elle dit des
raisons euh d'agir qu'elle soutient
que les raisons d'agir peuvent être
liées au contexte où elle argumente contre euh la
contrainte de généralité de Gareth Evans
et c'est la défense de l'idée d'
îlots de rationalité pratique,
donc elle traite toujours la rationalité comme
essentiellement quelque chose qui se rapporte
raisonner ici, mais ce genre de
raisonnement est limité  d par le
contexte pratique, c'est donc une
vision très progressiste si on la compare à la vision traditionnelle dont
j'ai parlé au début
mais toujours plus conservatrice que ce que
j'essaie de développer ici,
donc une autre chose qui, je pense, doit être
euh là-dedans l'avant-garde de cela  La proposition
est que la rationalité implique l'agence et l'
autonomie parce que quelque chose ou seulement
quelque chose qu'un organisme fait peut être
considéré comme rationnel,
donc pour utiliser ces euh les idées du
camp autonome et activiste et de
la théorie de la façon dont les joueurs sont
des systèmes autonomes tels que  un Roomba
ne peut pas être rationnel car ce n'est pas un
agent il n'est pas l'auteur de son propre
comportement il est conçu par des
agents externes pour fonctionner d'une certaine manière donc ce n'est
pas à proprement parler une nation donc
c'est là que je tracerais la ligne d'où
bien  vous ne pouvez pas cela n'a aucun sens d'
attribuer de la rationalité à un Roomba par
exemple
et
pour cela
j'utilise les notions d'autonomie et d'
adaptabilité du DiPaolo et d'autres vous
avez un  Aussi l'image du livre récent la
vie modèle à quatre sens et ce fameux
papier du bol de 2005 où il
parle de l'adaptabilité
à poser ses contraintes très générales
sur ce que signifie être russe
donc les systèmes autonomes sont ainsi
conçus comme des réseaux précaires a
réseau précaire de processus parce que l'
organisation et les frontières physiques sont
produites par le système lui-même le
système maintient continuellement ses propres
conditions de viabilité, ce qui est
connu sous le nom de création de sens où le
système a exploré
des conditions environnementales
favorables à son auto-entretien et
évite ceux qui lui sont préjudiciables,
c'est ainsi que je comprends être
le très en général qu'ils ont
une contrainte émotionnelle sur un être rationnel
que ce doit être un système autonome
et la chose intéressante ici est que
le concept d'adaptabilité que Paulo mais
est que la capacité d'un
organisme à améliorer sa condition
d'autoproduction par  h
changements structurels internes,
donc cela implique la surveillance et la
régulation des changements internes afin
de sélectionner le meilleur plan d'action disponible,
je pense que c'est un autre
concept intéressant à penser pour
inclure cette idée d'une
notion de rationalité radicalement inactive qui
n'est pas nécessairement attaché au
raisonnement et au contenu, de
sorte que l'agence est réalisée par l'
exercice de capacités situées qui
favorisent les changements au sein de l'organisme
conformément aux
contraintes environnementales et aux sous-stations,
ce qui signifie que la capacité d'un organisme à
s'adapter pour gérer
efficacement son environnement est une mesure  ou
une indication de sa
rationalité plus un organisme est rationnel, plus
il est apte à faire face à son
environnement et nous avons prévu des
circonstances
et ce faisant l'organisme améliore
les échanges continus entre lui
-même et l'environnement
qui sont cruciaux pour sa survie et
c'est une
façon très naturalisée de penser à la
rationalité  est principalement la capacité d'
améliorer les changements pour la survie,
c'est
l'idée générale ici,
donc comme je l'ai dit auparavant, qu'en est-il du raisonnement que
je veux,
je ne veux pas nécessairement engager la rationalité
avec le raisonnement et c'est
ce qu'est la rationalité radicalement inactive,
mais je  je ne veux pas exclure le
raisonnement en tant qu'ancienne combinaison rationnelle,
donc ce que je dis, c'est
qu'il n'est pas défini par le raisonnement mais ce n'est
pas euh cela n'exclut pas le raisonnement le
raisonnement, je pense, serait considéré comme
un mode spécial ou spécifique d'
agence rationnelle  celui qui est exclusif à notre
connaissance des êtres humains
mais ce n'est pas la caractéristique déterminante de la
rationalité
donc pour cela je euh afin d'expliquer
cette idée je rappelle comment Hutu et
Saturne entre l'article dans le livre le plus récent
d'utani ils expliquent le  l'émergence
d'une reconnaissance élevée, l'idée est que la
capacité de s'engager dans un contenu pour la
cognition dépend en fin de compte d'être
intégré culturellement socialement
là où la cognition complète du contenu a
émergé de la société.  Interaction culturelle iale afin
qu'un individu participe à
des pratiques culturelles sociales,
il accepte des capacités cognitives plus anciennes
pour gérer les symboles et,
ce faisant, il entre
dans un long processus d'enculturation,
bien sûr,
il devient capable de s'engager dans
une coordination symbolique qui n'est pas
interne.  représentation spécifique parce
qu'elle est accessible au public, ce ne sont pas des
représentations mentales au sens traditionnel,
mais elles ont les caractéristiques de la
cognition symbolique sans l'engagement envers
la représentation interne ou les représentations mentales,
donc agir rationnellement dans son
sens le plus général est l'idée que le
comportement compétent d'un  l'organisme est dans euh est
le comportement compétent d'un organisme
dans son environnement cela dépend de la
coordination des capacités incarnées
alors que le raisonnement si tout se passe
bien bien sûr est compris comme un contenu
pour la rationalité car mon mode spécifique de
rationalité le raisonnement est le
comportement compétent d'un  organisme dans un milieu
culturel social en  vironnement
qui est un aspect plus spécifique de notre
environnement bien sûr et cela dépend de
la coordination d'un tel
contenu culturel ou impliquant des capacités
qui sont plus récentes dans l'
échelle phylogénétique humaine
donc eh bien c'est la plus grande de l'
idée c'est la  la je pense
euh la partie propositionnelle et voici
les objections dont je voulais parler la
première étant que c'est une
vision très libérale c'est très
euh c'est bien ça englobe trop
on dirait parce que si l'action rationnelle
se résume à la coordination  des
capacités cognitives alors la rationalité est
quelque chose de graduel car un organisme pourrait
être plus ou moins compétent dans ses
interactions environnementales
et le rejet va selon
une rationalité radicalement inactive de nombreux
organismes atteignent et maintiennent un
comportement adaptatif dans la niche avec
différents niveaux de succès auxquels je
suis-je bien quelqu'un pourrait chanter des rationalités
radicales et actives rationnelles et actives
aux libéraux et c'est  une
objection que j'ai entendue en personne
et je l'ai gardée si dure parce que je pense que
c'est très c'est une très bonne façon de le
dire même si les ongles sont rationnels sur
cette vue et celle à laquelle je dois dire
que je suis prêt à acheter  le portefeuille
euh eh bien oui c'est plus libéral que
les vues traditionnelles bien sûr c'est
censé l'être mais je ne pense pas que
ce problème en soi ce que je pense est le
la partie positive ici est qu'il
préserve une différence de degré les
humains sont  bien plus rationnel que les autres
animaux simplement parce que nous sommes capables d'
effectuer une grande variété d'actions dans une
grande variété de circonstances dynamiques
qui sont bien au-delà de tout autre animal
dont nous sommes conscients,
donc pour revenir à l'exemple de ce
clou, ce clou peut  effectuer quelques
actions complexes peut se déplacer d'un point à
un autre, il peut chercher de la nourriture et un
abri, etc., mais ils ont
un ensemble limité de capacités critiques si
vous entourez ce clou avec le Sud,
par exemple, il est voué à mourir par
la rétorsion et les humains par
contre ils sont beaucoup plus adaptatifs et
capables de faire face dynamiquement à de nombreuses
circonstances imprévues donc euh
dans ma réponse à cette objection c'est que
oui
euh ben c'est très libéral mais ce n'est
pas le problème le problème serait si
ça  c'est s'il y avait de la place pour une
différence de degré entre la façon dont les
animaux gèrent leur
environnement et c'est l'autre
objection d'objet qui, je pense, peut être
bien que celle qui vous intéresse le plus, alors
vous savez est le 12 traitement prédictif
semble impliquer des inférences et du contenu
jusqu'au bout
euh mais dans un premier temps je dois euh vous avertir ainsi que
les téléspectateurs
qu'à l'époque où j'ai écrit cet euh cet article
était beaucoup plus optimiste quant à cette
possibilité de combiner un activisme et un
codage prédictif ou un
traitement prédictif et euh  Je pense qu'il y a
des points importants ici, mais il y a cet
article récent d'Olu et Evan Thompson
et Randy beer où ils
fournissent une évaluation critique de euh th
e les tentatives de combiner principalement
le principe de l'énergie libre et
um
théories inactives et autobiographiques donc je suis maintenant
principalement convaincu par les arguments mais je
pense qu'il y a quelques points
de comparaison intéressants ici néanmoins
processus donc prédictif dans notre
code prédictif et euh au  le temps que j'écrivais
et encore à ce jour fait fureur dans
les sciences cognitives, je suppose que vous pouvez
dire que cela sonnait que les bonbons deviennent l'
un des principaux paradigmes là-bas,
il est donc intéressant de voir s'il
correspond bien à ce que je  Je parle
et dans ces téléspectateurs, vous savez que la
concurrence est comprise comme un processus
de minimisation des erreurs qui se produit dans
des hiérarchies étroites bidirectionnelles
,
vous avez donc la génération de
modèles internes pour l'activité des couches inférieures
qui anticipe les causes distales des
stimuli sinistres qui est un  processus descendant
et la minimisation de l'
écart entre la prédiction et
le signal de stimulus actuel par
um l'occupation des priors qui  est un
fond de processus
donc voici bien sûr l'inférence active
qui est comprise par exemple dans
un informel vous savez les termes formels de
Clark qu'un organisme déplace ses capteurs
d'une manière qui revient à rechercher activement dans
notre génération générant les
conséquences sensorielles qu'ils sont plutôt  leur
cerveau s'attend à
ce que ce soit une façon de comprendre
les termes très formels d'influence active, mais je
pense que cela fait le travail,
donc le cerveau déduit la
source attendue des stimuli reçus
s'il semble qu'il y a un
problème avec ce que je suis  en parlant
donc la lecture de vote lui du
traitement prédictif qui utilise le
biais du produit et le droit d'inférence dit
par exemple que le processus de
perceptionistas est séparable du
processus de biais rationnel plus large de
prolification et des effets descendants du contexte
J'ai estimé que chaque
niveau intermédiaire de  le traitement de cela a attiré mon
attention de la façon dont Clark parle aussi
de rationalité tout du long,
mais c'est un  n une sorte de rationalité inférentielle
et un raisonnement d'influenceur omniprésent
semble impliquer un contenu omniprésent
, puis le traitement prédictif semble
être incompatible avec une rationalité radicalement inactive,
mais il y a euh à l'époque il y en
avait et je pense que nous pouvons encore discuter dans
plusieurs des il n'y a pas de
non  -les hémorroïdes et la lecture du
traitement prédictif
qui utilise par exemple une première étape
serait d'utiliser un sens déflationniste de la
prédiction qui comprend le camée dans un
court article de 2013 mais quatrième où
les valeurs de deux variables ou plus
covarient ou sont de valeur fiable de sorte que le
la valeur de 1 permet à l'observateur de déduire
la valeur d'un autre et ici l'
inférence se produit au
niveau de l'observation pas à une
variable éloignée déduit la valeur d'une
autre donc l'idée serait que je pense
que le contenu est dans l'œil de  le
spectateur la personne qui interprète comment
la sélection de censure que nous mettons se
rapproche des prédictions internes ici
comprises dans t  le sens inflationniste peut le
décrire en termes inférentiels et biaisés
, c'est ainsi que je vois par
exemple l'idée d'environ 4 000 par l'
article de Bruno qui, si je ne me trompe pas, le
titre est quelque chose comme le cerveau n'est pas
un scientifique et l'argument est en  cette
direction générale
que nous projetons comment les
scientifiques interprètent l'activité cérébrale comme une
caractéristique du cerveau lui-même comme
s'il prédisait et inférait ce sens plus
euh robuste ou plus lourd,
donc ce que j'essaie de dire ici, c'est que l'
inférence active alors j'utilise le double  et
dire double oublié le nom de cela en
anglais désolé
euh ce n'est pas euh le sens littéral de l'
inférence ici selon la
rationalité euh radicalement inactive est que désarmé pour l'
efficacité du comportement co-orienté l'
agent doit agir de certaines
manières pour son  ses états se
concrétisent plus efficacement moins cher
cela n'implique pas l'affirmation plus controversée
que les modèles génératifs
eux-mêmes affichent et effectuent
des inférences prédictives  es c'est une
lecture très déflationniste du
traitement prédictif pour fournir cette
combinaison avec une rationalité radicale et active
et voici un coup d'envoi dans un article de
par modèle, il ne s'ensuit pas qu'un
organisme a un
modèle de représentation interne de sa niche en
ce qu'il  est ce modèle que ceux-ci sont le
travail cognitif si vous aimez plutôt un
organisme est un modèle qui est les
régularités causales et statistiques reflètent dans
un environnement reflétant un
phénotype qui est un modèle
et bien
cela se rapporte à quelque chose qui a récemment
euh mon collègue notifica et moi  ont
parlé de l'idée de la façon dont les organismes
produisent un monde selon un
activisme qui est l'idée que l'organisme
et l'environnement sont
historiquement appelés déterminés, donc
à l'échelle génétique du flux, cela
pourrait s'expliquer par l'idée de construction de niche
l'idée qu'une fois  un
organisme est actif dans son environnement il
favorise des changements qui s'ils sont
suffisamment stables  Ils peuvent être hérités par sa
progéniture et ces changements fournissent de nouvelles
pressions de pression évolutives
qui mènent son chemin évolutif
une idée similaire a également été explorée par une
autre description cette fois concernant la
construction de niche
et la psychologie écologique
donc ma réponse à cette objection est
qu'agir rationnellement signifie parvenir à
un engagement compétent avec l'
environnement grâce à la prédiction
et à leur minimisation, je suis prêt à
accepter cette caractérisation, mais
les processus biaisés rationnels et plus larges
n'ont pas besoin d'impliquer un contenu pour la cognition
si nous comprenons cela dans le Flash  la
prédiction sans sens et leur minimisation
impliquent la sélection d'entrées et la
coordination d'une interabilités dans les
mœurs d'implication du monde qui est bien
exactement la revendication principale d'
une personnalité radicale et active donc je pense dans cette
mesure que le traitement prédictif n'est pas
euh un ennemi serait plutôt  qu'un mensonge
de cette idée au lieu de euh
arrivée mais de c  ourse il y a d'autres
problèmes de compatibilité que j'ai
que je n'ai pas abordés ici mais c'est tout ce à quoi
j'ai pensé pour aujourd'hui merci
génial merci beaucoup d'
accord
cool très intéressant
pour ceux qui regardent en direct s'il vous plaît
n'hésitez pas à  écrire des questions, je
rassemblerai mes notes et commençons la
discussion d'
accord, d'
abord, merci encore pour la
discussion,
que diriez-vous d'un peu de contexte sur la façon dont vous en êtes
venu à poser ces questions dans
votre poste actuel et comment vos
intérêts dans ce domaine se sont développés parce
qu'il y a  tant d'idées intéressantes et je
voulais juste en savoir plus sur la façon dont vous êtes
arrivé à ce cadrage et affiné votre
point d'
accord merci c'est une bonne
question car ce n'est pas souvent que vous
pouvez explorer ce contexte
c'est important alors euh j'étais à l'époque où je
Je pense que j'écrivais ma thèse de
doctorat c'était peut-être en 2007 ou quelque chose comme ça et euh
je défendais l'idée que la
rationalité doit être quelque chose qui est
finalement impliqué dans le monde  dans il y a une
tendance à bien penser même parmi comme
je l'ai dit comme je vous l'ai montré parmi euh dans des
périodes incarnées avec des gens de certains
cela doit être essentiellement Monde
impliquant comme l'action et la pratique
et ainsi de suite
et la perception bien sûr mais la rationalité
reste  quelque chose comme une
notion naturalisable quelque chose qui ne peut pas être
ramené au niveau du ça
ne peut pas être réduit d'une manière
comme la perception qui pourrait s'expliquer
par un certain engagement dynamique et ainsi
de suite ainsi de suite
donc à l'époque je pensais que bien
peut-être s'agit-il d'
un problème de genou, car
dans d'
autres contextes, cela implique que
quelle que soit la perception, si elle n'est pas
articulée de manière à fournir un
certain ajustement avec la combinaison professionnelle,
la perception est une donnée
et c'est le mythe de la
dimension donnée  au début et j'ai pensé
que bon peut-être que c'est quelque chose d'
il y a quelque chose d'un mythe du
donné travaillant ici sur une
cognition active mais ce n'est pas je le pense  n'est
pas fatal parce que nous ne pouvions pas
affirmer en principe qu'au lieu d'
interpréter la perception des étapes et d'
autres formes de base de combinaisons
impliquant des concepts et autres, nous pourrions peut-être
argumenter
dans l'autre sens, essayer de
réduire la rationalité à un niveau plus non
naturalisé de
euh
donc c'était la motivation et c'était
très c'était un long processus de révision et je
crois que ma première la première version
de l'article le spectateur était très je
pense qu'ils avaient tout à fait raison j'ai
approuvé la suggestion après tout mais il
était très euh
ils  étaient très catégoriques pour prendre cette
partie et je pense que c'était pour le mieux
parce que c'est une autre littérature
c'est une autre euh beaucoup de références qui
ne sont pas d'habitude en conversation avec un
activisme et une reconnaissance corporelle et c'était
très difficile juste de mettre le  importe dans
les mêmes termes d'avancer mes arguments
donc c'est quelque chose que j'ai rayé
et je n'ai pas trop réfléchi à
ce système mais je pense que c'est quelque chose que
j'aimerais  pour revenir et peut-être euh
même probablement quelqu'un l'a
fait ces dernières années je ne sais pas je
me souviens mais
cette relation entre un activisme le
mythe du don et il semblait être il
semble être très
évident  donc c'est je pense quelque chose que
nous pourrions nous devrions je veux dire euh pouvoir
explorer mais il n'y a pas quelque chose qui
était au premier plan du papier
mais
mais j'ai eu cette idée de parler de
rationalité dans tous les sens
et en même temps  le temps je lisais beaucoup
sur euh l'
appelait d'un
point de vue philosophique bien sûr je ne suis pas comme je l'ai dit
très bien versé dans les technicités
et les formalités de l'approche
mais j'étais intéressé par les
conséquences philosophiques là et j'ai
bien réfléchi  peut-être qu'il y a quelque chose à
comparer ici parce que comme le montre la citation de Clark,
vous pouvez parler de rationalité
jusqu'au bout et euh c'est quelque chose que je
voulais développer mais pas dans une vision cognitiviste mais pas dans un
film radicalement incarné donc
c'est l'arrière-plan
génial merci pourriez-vous peut
-être décrire ce qu'est le mythe du
donné quel était le contexte dans lequel ce
mythe est né et où allons-nous après
avoir évoqué le mythe du donné
parce que je le voyais comme un concept qui  vous avez
tissé alors de quoi s'agissait-il d'
accord, donc au milieu de la donner,
il y a plusieurs données possibles en
fonction de votre saveur
de ma philosophie, mais le plus classiquement dans les
domaines précédents de l'esprit, prenez le
contenu de la perception à donner  prière
rationnellement de manière à ce que nous ayons certaines
entrées qui sont euh juste reçues par l'
esprit et l'esprit l'interprète de sorte que les
vendeurs différents vendeurs sont célèbres pour
avoir décrit son euh ce problème comme
un problème non seulement pour augmenter les carburants
de l'esprit mais aussi  pour les rationalistes,
mais de l'autre côté, le rationnel est
généralement pris euh l'intuition rationnelle comme une
donnée, c'est-à-dire qu'il existe un
certain niveau de cognition qui est euh
inarticulé qu'il '  est donné ou comme certaines
personnes parlent d'être élevé,
mais d'une certaine manière, il y a ce niveau de
cognition qui est donné et l'esprit doit
l'interpréter, mais s'il est donné de
cette manière, il n'a aucun point de contact, aucune
intersection entre quoi que ce soit
quoi que l'esprit fasse et et ce
niveau de base de euh domination donc mon idée est d'
éviter l'accusation d'être engagé
dans le mythe du donné mais encore une fois ce
n'est pas quelque chose qui est explicite dans
la littérature nativiste mais c'est
quelque chose qui semble être  possible
de développer dans un
je veux dire euh dans ce genre de comparaison mais
ce n'est pas du
pas clairement là mais
une façon de les résoudre pour les Givens
de dire que le contenu perceptif est
déjà de nature conceptuelle, ce qui est
par exemple comment Joe McDowell  fait à l'
esprit plus de cela vous connaissez une
perception euh la blague est livrée avec des
sous-titres vous et interprétez le monde
comme vous le faites mais euh
je pense qu'une façon ou une autre est
de démystifier vous connaissez une rationalité  et
les couches supérieures de combinaison
essaient d'y penser euh euh en moins
euh de contenu pour l'analyse
sans les engager donc c'est à proprement
parler avec un niveau de contenu qui est
divorcé des niveaux de base de
combinaison c'est une façon je pense de le
faire et  la rationalité semble être
le concept clé pour ce faire,
car tout est généralement supposé être quelque chose d'
exclusivement humain et quelque chose qui est
lié au raisonnement et bien si c'est le
cas, alors la rationalité ne peut pas informer l'action
et si bien sûr si l'action est
de nature sans contenu  donc si la rationalité
est un sens essentiellement content et que la
réaction est essentiellement non contenue pour sans
contenu alors vous pouvez vous n'avez pas
euh ça c'est fait cette euh intersection
entre deux domaines et c'est
quelque chose que je voulais éviter mais comme je
vous l'ai dit c'est devenu si dur de  exprimer
ce point de vue de manière
suffisamment claire et générale, c'est
que, sur la recommandation de notre critique,
j'efface cela et
j'y pense toujours  t mais rien que je
n'ai pas développé une
ligne d'argumentation appropriée qui traite de cela
plus clairement que je ne peux le faire comme je viens de le faire
en termes très généraux
cool bien certains mots que vous avez associés
à la rationalité étaient l'adaptabilité
et aussi la compétence alors que voyez-vous
comme la relation entre la rationalité et la
forme physique en
tant que fonction biologique d'accord oui ouais d'
accord
je pense que c'est une
relation intrinsèque vraiment je pense que c'est
euh probablement la conséquence la plus
[musique]
euh
évidente de l'action rationnelle
à une échelle particulière et quand  nous parlons
de savoir si la rationalité est une caractéristique
de certaines espèces ou au lieu d'
individus, je pense que la forme physique est l'un
des concepts clés ici pour penser que cela
est le résultat de cette
action rationnelle,
même si je ne dis pas que je ne le fais pas
mettez-le dans ces questions dans le journal, je
pense qu'il est possible de le penser de cette
façon, vous savez, ne le voyez pas
comme une objection à penser à la
rationalité, mais encore une fois, c'est très libéral
et je suis prêt à  o d'accepter cette
conséquence ainsi que chaque
organisme vivant d'une certaine manière s'il n'est pas encore
passé à l'Instinct donc il est d'une certaine manière
adapté à son environnement donc je suis prêt
à voir que cela peut impliquer un
niveau minimal de rationalité de  faire face à euh
l'environnement changeant de l'ennemi
mais bon et c'est le prix d'avoir une
notion progressiste très euh libérale des
rationalités c'est une conséquence de
cela je crois
donc vous avez dit que la forme physique est une
conséquence du comportement rationnel y a-
t-il d'autres conséquences ou  comment reconnaissons-nous la
rationalité de l'extérieur
autre que de simplement dire que la
colonie de fourmis est florissante dans la mesure où
elle est rationnelle, elle est adaptative une
agence d'exposition et tout cela
euh est-ce un
concept de rationalité tellement déflationniste que toutes les choses existantes,
les humains et  sinon sont simplement
décrits par lui ou y a-t-il des
résultats que nous pouvons utiliser pour démêler
comme par exemple un comportement rationnel ou
irrationnel des simples
conséquences reflétées par su  Revival et
Fitness bien, j'ai dû réfléchir très
attentivement à cela parce que je ne
veux pas banaliser ce concept d'une manière
qui bien tout est IPS de fait ou
rationnel par le fait que c'est
vivre c'est agir relation mais je
pense que euh dans des cas particuliers, on
pourrait euh identifier la nation que je suis
égal aux individus
um autosuffisance dans cette niche donc
au niveau individuel en particulier d'
accord c'est une action concluante
qui pourrait classifier
irrationnelle dans la mesure où ils  euh
sont préjudiciables à à la survie mais
euh au niveau de l'espèce c'est plus
difficile d'argumenter comme ça parce que
pour identifier ce genre de comportement ou de
conséquence mais je pense que
pour ne pas banaliser l'idée de
rationnel et bien dire tout ce qui est
la vie est une factorisation que vous devriez
identifier ce genre d'actes particuliers
qui nuisent
à une survie
donc dans le cas de la colonie de fourmis, je
ne sais peut-être pas
accueillir des envahisseurs serait un
serait le genre de comportement qui
serait préjudiciable à la
survie en tant que telle
je ne sais pas je ne sais pas si c'est euh
c'est une façon impossible de penser
à cela je devais penser plus clairement
mais
mon  soigneusement
oh très intéressant et vous avez apporté
dans cette réponse et dans la présentation
comme plusieurs
échelles de temps imbriquées, tout comme Eco Evo
Devo le fait d'un
point de vue plus biologique en regardant comment la
construction de niche comble le fossé entre
les processus phylogénétiques plus lents et
les processus de développement plus rapides
um so  comment cette considération
intégrée et multi-échelle est-elle
liée au
concept de contenu, comme le contenu va-t-il être
localisé dans un corps ou le contenu est-il
distribué à travers les entités ou la
rationalité est-elle distribuée à travers les entités
comment pourrions-nous même identifier le lieu
de la rationalité et que  invoque également en quelque sorte
la conception horizontale et modulaire
de la citation que vous avez
fournie, alors comment identifions-nous les éléments saillants
échelles spatio-temporelles et systèmes d'
intérêt
oh ah je ne sais pas je ne sais pas si je peux
répondre euh à ça complètement mais il me semble
qu'au niveau de euh si on parle
de contenu par exemple le contenu comme
précision  conditions pour les
pensées symboliques je pense heureusement que nous devons
dire que ce n'est pas localisé chez un
seul individu c'est partagé publiquement
donc vous pouvez dire que
euh
une conséquence de cela est qu'il est
possible de penser à différents
modes de raisonnement euh qui ont
été des
sites d'information  à différents moments Etc et vous pouvez
voir qu'ils ont bien développé des
règles de niveau différent pour les
informations sur le contenu
et je pense qu'il est
plausible de dire que le contenu
est localisé que le
euh comment pouvez-vous dire qu'il partage le montant dont
vous connaissez les spécificités de
juste pour la rationalité, je pense que l'
on pourrait
[Musique]
identifier des comportements particuliers
si cela correspond à ces euh
ce genre de description de euh spin
compétent compétent interaction et
adaptatif  l'interaction entre un organisme
et son environnement sa niche donc
probablement nous pourrions
nous pourrions donner des réponses différentes ici en tant
que rationalité et contenu je suis prêt
à dire que le
contenu pour l'organisation n'est pas
quelque chose qui se passe dans la tête
quelque chose qui est là-bas d'une manière
partager  la quantité d'autres et c'est
quelque chose que ma philosophie
a au moins depuis les années 60,
mes philosophes ont
soutenu l'idée que le contenu est
individué de l'extérieur
et euh je pense que c'est l'une
des vidéos de  par exemple Hillary Putnam
et Tyler Burge et d'autres que le
contenu mental est individualisé au
niveau communautaire ou au niveau sociétal,
mais là-bas, d'un autre côté, ils pensent que la
rationalité pourrait en principe être
individualisée dans des comportements particuliers, mais
cela dépendrait des objectifs de l'individu
et de la  la niche qu'il occupe et
ainsi de suite,
il y a bien sûr
ici des variables réelles qui pourraient également être importantes
pour identifier le
comportement  aussi rationnel ou pas d'
accord
merci
euh bien une phrase qui m'a vraiment
marqué était comme savoir comment ne pas savoir que
peut-être euh un point basal dans votre travail
et un accent sur cette action donc je
voulais juste
savoir comment l'action et la pratique comme
vous tissé  eux ici aujourd'hui comment ces termes sont-ils
abordés
et en quoi les choses sont-elles différentes aujourd'hui avec
le traitement de l'action et de la pratique et du
savoir-faire ne savent pas cela que de dire dans le
helmholtzee en jours ou même dans les
traditions anciennes ou dans la connaissance du monde
Alors d'accord cool alors l'idée  Je pense que ce serait
euh
il y a une tendance de euh c'est une
tendance d'une philosophie très moderne
mais cela a été très influent dans la
première vague des sciences cognitives de penser à la
perception comme
une capacité à catégoriser l'environnement
et à offrir un discret  description des
aspects environnementaux donc par exemple
percevoir que euh le le le
que je sais que la tasse est à ma gauche est
une question de savoir qu'il y a une
chose avec des recherches telles propriétés à
ma gauche et c'est une sorte de euh sais
qu'une sorte d'attitude propositionnelle
envers le monde donc
euh je pense que la
chose intéressante à propos d'un activisme et d'
une psychologie écologique aussi et dans la
mesure où ils rappellent le
pragmatisme américain du début de  le
siècle est de penser à la
perception comme une question de ne pas
catégoriser ces grandes propriétés dans
le monde mais comme euh révélant des
possibilités d'agir
et c'est quelque chose que si nous devions
expliquer cela en termes euh en
termes épidémiques tels que la connaissance, nous le ferions '  Je ne le mets
pas comme une question de savoir que la
courbe est à ma gauche mais de savoir
saisir la tasse et faire ce que je veux en
faire si je veux boire une tasse de
café ou si je veux l'utiliser comme un
presse-papiers, il aura différentes
propriétés silencieuses et c'est quelque chose
qui,
bien que cela ait été je pense
très, je pense qu'un activisme et une
psychologie écologique et d'autres visions incarnées de la
cognition ont largement réussi
à changer  amenant cette discussion à ce
point, je pense que dans les
sciences cognitives plus traditionnelles, vous avez toujours
l'idée que les
organismes bien perçus par en
décrivant la façon dont l'
environnement est quelque chose que je pense que
les lectures plus traditionnelles du
traitement prédictif rendent clair
comme dans euh l'idée que vous inférez
sur la source des stimuli et non
dans euh et non et ce n'est pas je veux dire
cela se prête plus facilement à l'idée
que le cerveau ou le
système cognitif sait que
le monde est  tel ou tel
l'environnement est tel ou tel au lieu de
dire que le système d'agenda sait
comment s'engager avec le monde et je crois
que le point
qu'un activiste et euh des
psychologues écologiques essaient de faire est
de travailler également sur le prédictif
le codage et le principe d'énergie libre
Etc est de montrer que ces notions ces
cadres pourraient être une idée minimale que
le système kubernetes sait comment
s'engager il sait comment s'engager  ge dans l'
environnement d'une manière qu'il n'est pas nécessaire
de lire le résumé
intégré que le système Kindle en déduit
que le monde est ainsi, donc je pense que c'est
une façon d'expliquer mais aussi euh
philosophiquement si vous avez un grand
au début de  au cours des dernières
décennies, euh, une discussion gigantesque sur la question de
savoir si aucun nuage ne pouvait être réduit à
savoir cela, puis encore une fois, vous avez un
arrière-plan de ceci et d'autres
en tant que notion indépendante de vous savez
cela et si vous pouviez
réduire l'un à l'autre et ainsi de suite  donc
je pense que ça ne s'arrête pas là, vous ne pouvez pas
euh même si je peux faire une réclamation pour la
perception d'un autre sachant comment
ils sont toujours la question
de fond de savoir si le savoir-faire pourrait être traité comme
et tout ça de
toute façon c'est quelque chose qui  Je
travaille aussi sur récemment
il y a beaucoup à dire là-bas
c'est une idée tellement intéressante surtout avec la
communication linguistique c'est un
peu comme le doigt et la lune et
parler de la lune mais le doigt n'est
que  où il se trouve et nous ne parlons
pas du pointeur, nous parlons de
la référence
et donc d'utiliser
une forme de communication sociocognitive
dans un langage cultivé
ou dans un discours académique écrit pour regarder à
travers cela ou pour réimaginer cela et
voir même ce qui semble  être comme le
Pinacle de savoir ça
et toujours le voir comme savoir comment
je suppose que la question est de
savoir comment lire les journaux
oui bien sûr oui je pense que c'est euh c'est
un
euh c'est ouais les valeurs qu'il semble
pouvoir être  un très gros problème parce que si
on essaie de traiter ces
capacités négatives comme vous l'avez mentionné comme une question
de savoir-faire
il semble qu'il nous manque encore quelque chose
sur la communication par exemple et
d'un autre côté je pense et c'est mon
intuition mais je pense  que nous pourrions en
principe parler de la
façon dont
comprendre ce que vous venez de dire et
essayer d'y répondre est une question de
savoir comment se comporter linguistiquement,
mais je pense que même ce mouvement
pour traiter des niveaux élevés de cognitions
qui m'ont fait  t une question de savoir-faire, il
laisse encore quelque chose de côté
je suis je veux dire personnellement je suis et j'en suis
satisfait je pense qu'à un certain
niveau nous devons dire que c'est
un autre type d'approche qui est nécessaire
ici pour expliquer comment nous  communiquer par
exemple de
manière très adéquate pour ne pas dire que cela
n'implique pas et maintenant mais ce n'est pas seulement
que je pense qu'au moins plus que
des connaissances pratiques sont nécessaires,
mais peut-être que la clé ici est de penser à des
connaissances pratiques juste basiques et
nécessaires pour d'autres sortes  d'autres
types de connaissances dont ils ont besoin
pour s'engager dans ce type d'échange
peut-être que c'est peut-être une couche,
je suis sûr que
bien
euh il faut en
dire plus à ce sujet pour donner une
réponse plus informative, mais c'est un à
moins ma position actuelle est que
non comment fournit la base de notre
engagement avec le monde et avec les
autres, mais à un moment donné, nous
devons être en mesure de développer d'autres types de
compréhension pour expliquer très expliquer
les types complexes de euh  les échanges que nous
avons dans nos vies quotidiennes
comme la lecture d'articles comme vous l'avez dit
je suis d'accord je pense que
cadrer savoir que comme base et ensuite
récupérer le savoir-faire est un défi et
c'est aussi un défi de commencer par les
processus cognitifs de base comme étant
mis en œuvre sans maison et  de réassembler ces
pièces de savoir-faire pour savoir qu'encore une fois
ce n'est même pas nécessairement un simple
défi mais devrions-nous plutôt
relever le défi d'assembler des processus cognitifs symboliques
propositionnels déclaratifs verbaux
Etc à partir d'une
approche cognitive écologique plus liminale
ou essayer de récupérer l'écologique
du turing  machine dans un sens, il
semble donc
euh
que vous parliez en faveur de l'ancrage
dans des processus cognitifs basaux écologiques plausibles
, puis que vous travaillez à l'
assemblage du gratte-ciel
oui oui ouais totalement ouais je pense que c'est
bien les
deux euh
ces deux approches sont difficiles
à assembler  comme vous l'avez dit pour fournir
ce genre d'explication, soit en
bas à gauche, soit en haut, mais je  suis
bien sûr plus favorable à l'approche du web
je le pense aussi pour une autre
raison il semble que le point de
départ semble être
une description biologique de la façon dont nous
interagissons avec le monde et l'
inverse semble être beaucoup plus
difficile  pour expliquer euh comment nous arrivons
à ces questions biologiques telles
que notre morphologie corporelle et il semble
que nous devons d'abord en tenir compte
et ensuite vous nous arrivons aux autres
questions auxquelles il est également difficile de
répondre mais au tout  moins je pense que
c'est
une approche ascendante qui est plus euh
intégrative d'une certaine manière, c'est qu'il y a des chances que
cela semble être plus
euh en notre faveur dans le sens
et et la façon dont vous venez de l'encadrer
m'a fait penser que si vous étiez  pour
programmer un ordinateur à partir de zéro,
il peut s'agir d'un ordinateur abstrait ou virtuel,
de sorte qu'il n'a même pas besoin d'avoir
un mode de réalisation spécifique
et dans cette situation, on pourrait être
concerné par l'assemblage de
savoir qui affirment cela et l'assemblage de
ces déclarations  les
déclarations atives et les processus logiques en
quelque chose qui est plus dynamique ou en
interaction avec l'environnement, mais
ce processus comme l'ingénierie complète
avec la logique et le silicone à la base
est assez différent de la façon dont nous sommes arrivés ici
et donc ça pourrait, mais c'est
complémentaire
euh bien  vous avez donné un peu de visibilité
sur euh, je suppose, l'avant, pendant et
après l'examen par les pairs, donc j'étais juste
curieux de savoir ce qui a
changé pendant et après l'article au
cours des derniers mois ou années ou quelle que soit la
durée, comment avez-vous évolué à ce sujet
et ensuite quoi  voyez-vous comme les
prochaines étapes pertinentes, qu'elles soient pour vous ou
simplement générales à faire recherchons-
nous une mesure du cerveau recherchons-
nous une caméra vidéo dans une forêt
recherchons-nous une avancée conceptuelle ce qui
va aller de l'avant  vos
développements c'est une excellente question je pense
euh
je ne suis pas complètement satisfait de la
façon dont j'utiliserai le niveau étranger je ne sais pas
si cela serait
réalisé ou  t en euh je ne sais franchement pas
si tu pourrais en principe effectuer en d'
autres termes empiriques mais
euh je ne dis pas que euh bon
on est je l'écrirais un peu
différemment aujourd'hui pas que c'est euh pas
que je ne sois pas d'accord avec le  papier à l'
origine mais je pense qu'il
y a quelque chose certains points que
j'aimerais recadrer mais ils n'autorisent pas
euh non plus je pense qu'il avait un nouveau
papier
mais peut-être dans le futur mais c'est
quelque chose que
les questions comme le mythe ont
donné qui est  toujours la question philosophique
et conceptuelle ils me dérangent toujours euh
mais je n'ai pas
encore trouvé l'occasion de développer ces
idées plus attentivement et la vue générale que
j'ai présentée là je pense je pense que
ça tient toujours
euh mais
euh
j'aimerais je je  j'attends toujours
cette chance de l'élaborer davantage et de
voir jusqu'où je peux aller mais je ne sais pas
encore je dois admettre que je ne sais pas quels sont
les développements futurs de cette idée
mais euh j'ai travaillé  sur plusieurs
problèmes isolés  s sur cette
approche depuis quelques années je travaille avec
la notion d'information et de
compréhension scientifique et d'information pour l'
écologique et un activiste de la
combinaison et depuis peu je travaille
plus récemment avec quelques collèges sur
la réalité virtuelle et la
reconnaissance de la perception donc euh
ça  c'est comme ça que j'aime mener mes
recherches pour trouver des
questions intéressantes et voir comment puis-je les
traiter mais pas nécessairement me retrouver
euh lié à une
seule ligne de raisonnement de cette façon, donc
c'est ce qui s'est passé à l'époque avec laquelle je
travaillais  la rationalité si je pensais que
c'était un sujet très cool et euh je
pense toujours que ça l'est mais je n'ai pas eu le temps
de revenir et de recadrer ce que je
voulais mais euh peut-être peut-être dans
un futur proche je ne sais pas mais plus  la
chose la plus récente sur laquelle j'ai travaillé
n'implique pas la rationalité cellulaire,
mais je pense que certains produits
pourraient être erronés, à savoir celui d'une
réalité virtuelle et
comment la réalité visuelle se
compare-t-elle réellement à la com  bination parce que
bon y'a forcément quelque chose qui manque
à une persévérance et à un environnement visuel
euh il y en a bien sûr si moi quelqu'un par
exemple si si je suis sur un
environnement visuel où je suis sous une sorte de
menace je peux ressentir quelque chose d'analogue à la
peur mais  Je ne crains pas vraiment pour ma
vie
et j'imagine que la personne sur la
réalité virtuelle est-il donc rationnel
de fuir
la menace la menace virtuelle et ainsi
de suite ainsi de suite c'est ça la c'est
ce que je travaille  sur et euh c'est peut-être que ça
donne un point de retour à ça
l'idée de rationalité radicale et active
et en fait euh le papier
vient d'être accepté donc comme je
vous le disais avant j'étais tellement occupé ces derniers
jours parce qu'on corrigeait des épreuves
mon  collègues et moi n'avons jamais eu de figuratif
euh et j'avais aussi
un calendrier serré
pour soumettre la version corrigée de l'
article au cours des dernières semaines, puis j'ai
eu les épreuves et
oh
euh eh bien peut-être euh à l'avenir je pourrai
revenir à l'iss  ue de rationalité
j'aimerais bien mais je ne sais pas si je
ne sais pas je ne peux vraiment pas prévoir les
évolutions de ça mais euh en général je suis
toujours d'accord avec mon idée de départ mais
je vais la cadrer un peu différemment  un peu
donc le point VR je suis sûr qu'il y a
beaucoup plus à dire là-bas mais cela m'a
rappelé juste le titre réalité virtuelle c'est une
virtualisation et donc de la même manière
que
la planification de l'action cognitive
nous permet d'entreprendre des
politiques que notre corps ne fait pas  t prendre
ne serait-ce que pour les évaluer et choisir
contre eux, mais nous pouvons aller de l'avant avec un processus
de sélection de politique fantaisiste de contrefactuels
mentalement,
mais alors notre morphologie est un peu comme
notre Lifeline, vous savez si vous
tombez réellement d'un rebord alors c'est  va faire mal
et ensuite dans la réalité virtuelle
vous êtes incarné
l'expérience perceptive est littéralement
une virtualisation des
situations critiques de survie donc vous
pourriez vous voir comme étant sur un rebord
mais vous êtes sur un sol plat
et ensuite dans cette situation
si vous êtes un peu
euh un observateur cognitif en dehors du
jeu vidéo, vous pourriez dire que c'est
rationnel pour moi juste de tomber pour voir
ce qui se passe
donc c'est comme mais alors il y a une couche
de rationalité dans l'espace oui comme
ce qui est un bon coup  dans le jeu
euh et donc ça brouille la frontière
entre
[Musique
] c'est brouiller la criticité
du corps et euh
je suis sûr que vous y avez beaucoup
plus réfléchi alors comment cela joue-t-il dans notre
réalité virtuelle
euh avec le  comment nous pensons, utilisons
et concevons bien ces systèmes,
ce sont les
questions qui nous ont motivés à écrire un
article et euh NADA leur a donné et j'étais
que dans la littérature technique, vous voyez
que beaucoup de chercheurs travaillent avec
le  euh traiter euh la perception visuelle comme
illustri une sorte d'Illusion mais ça nous a
un peu dérangé car d'un
autre côté ça ne marche qu'en VR parce que
nous on a incarné les appareils les appareils ils
marchent pour nous vous avez les manettes vous
avez la tête  ensemble
et euh ça semble tellement bizarre de dire que l'
utilisateur l'utilisateur est sous une sorte d'
Illusion
et d'un autre côté il semble que ce n'est
pas réellement de la cognition parce que comme vous l'avez
dit il n'y a pas de
pertinence biologique euh pour ceux euh cognitifs
États pour ainsi dire par exemple si je vois
une pomme en VR c'est qu'elle ne permet pas de se
nourrir mais cela a du sens dans le
jeu, mais les différents euh bien
bien j'ai reçu une pomme dans un
environnement réel c'est qu'elle se
nourrit  c'est quelque chose que je peux manger
mais pas en VR je peux faire semblant donc nous avons
inventé ce euh concept d'allusion à
son avion
euh c'est comme si nous étions
face à un animal réel mais cela implique
aussi cette volonté de jouer cette idée
que nous ne sommes pas
être induit en erreur parce que nous mettons l'
équipement que nous savons que nous sommes dans le jeu
et je pense que c'est un sujet brûlant en ce moment
parce qu'il y a des métaphores et je suis très
sceptique sur tout ce
qui peut les gens sont très optimistes mais
sur les possibilités de la métave  rse
et certains auteurs pensent vraiment que nous
pourrions être dans une simulation à
proprement parler mais je veux dire la meilleure
technologie que la technologie actuelle
nous montre est qu'elle est très limitée et vous pouvez
prétendre être dans un certain environnement
et ainsi de suite et je pense que  peut offrir
de nouvelles façons de
penser à la rationalité dans cet
environnement visuel de manière à ce que les Russes fassent peut-être
quelque chose que l'environnement
a dit de sauter du rebord et de voir
ce qui se passe et d'autre part
les aspects comportementaux de le faire parfois les
gens se sentent réellement  la peur et les gens
font face à la rue pour les phobies avec les réalités virtuelles
et
euh c'est beaucoup de
questions intéressantes là-bas que
je veux peut-être dire pour les recherches futures, nous pouvons
oui y revenir, cela m'a fait réfléchir à la
façon dont Apple dans la vraie vie  ça pourrait être des
calories pour vous mais ça pourrait aussi être des
calories pour une mouche ça pourrait être jeté
vous pourriez l'utiliser comme un marteau vous pourriez le
peindre correctement donc l'
écologie et la générative  processus comme
nous dirions qu'une sorte d'inférence active
va toujours au-delà de
toutes les affordances programmées
pour un objet donné et puis aussi
euh le discours actuel sur la réalité virtuelle se concentre
fortement sur les casques
juste pour parler de manière totalement anecdotique pas
pas mon domaine d'expertise
euh il semble un  un peu intéressant,
c'est comme si la discussion sur le téléphone portable
ne se concentrait que sur des
rectangles d'une certaine taille,
ce qui fait que ce n'est pas une réalité virtuelle, c'est
comme regarder à travers une fenêtre et
il y a un autre type avec qui parler, donc
ce n'est pas attaché à ma tête, ce n'est pas le cas
avoir certaines des capacités de suivi de mouvement
um que certaines technologies
ont, mais c'est
une modification de niche dans l'espace personnel de Perry
et nous pouvons pousser des
signaux et des affordances les uns aux autres,
donc avoir un cadrage VR ou vraiment juste un
cadrage de la rationalité et de la perception
cognition action Cycles
qui
ne sont pas simplement limités à une
réalisation spécifique ou à un type de matériel et peuvent couvrir
toute la gamme de la personne hors ligne totale
dans un champ
à s  quelqu'un qui est très
dans The Matrix
semble assez pertinent sinon les nouvelles
technologies même les petites variantes et
les mises à jour logicielles continueront de
surprendre et de confondre à l'infini
ouais je pense que c'est un c'est un c'est difficile de
définir les limites
je veux dire nous sommes ici euh dans un échange
qui  Je pense que cela pourrait augmenter mais être
classé comme une forme de réalité virtuelle
bien sûr je vous vois ruiner votre
esprit C mais
euh je veux dire la plupart je pense que ça marche ils de
nos jours ils le trouvent un doc en
disant ça faut bien avoir un casque  et
parfois un contrôleur mais mais à part
ça, ça sonne la réalité virtuelle mais
ouais c'est difficile de définir quoi que ce soit euh
ce n'est pas ce n'est pas un dépotoir et
simple c'est une des choses
parce que sur euh parler commercialement
bien sûr la réalité virtuelle signifie des casques
et et d'autres accessoires mais mais mais  un
téléphone qui parlait simplement au téléphone ou un
télégraphe à cette époque, il aurait
été sur cette interface avec cette
modalité sensorielle et avec ces affordances
c'est  la virtualisation
ouais à laquelle nous avons accès d'un
chapitre différent aujourd'hui
ouais je pense que oui une partie de notre article
consistait à affirmer que d'une manière incarnant
des dispositifs technologiques est évidemment dans
le besoin non ce n'est pas nouveau c'est la
marque d'être humain
c'est  incarner des appareils technologiques
ce qui a fait de nous ce que nous sommes depuis le
début en utilisant la technologie analytique et
le fait que nous pouvons l'incarner si
efficacement un appareil même s'il est
programmé pour par exemple euh dans
la réalité virtuelle pour avoir quelque chose une
créature avec laquelle vous nous contrôlez plus riche  nouvelle
morphologie une autre morphologie par
exemple même si c'est le cas, cela ne
se produit que si efficacement parce que nous sommes
capables d'incarner l'appareil certaines
expériences ont montré que vous pouvez mapper
par exemple une torsion de votre poignet à un
troisième bras
euh que la réalité individuelle va d'était
que depuis votre poitrine et les gens peuvent
apprendre à contrôler ce troisième bras qui
ne correspond pas à notre morphologie réelle,
mais il peut être rendu ainsi par un Twist o  f le
poignet,
c'est donc quelque chose dont nous discuterons dans
notre article et bien
vous ne pouvez le faire que parce que vous incarnez
l'appareil que vous pouvez voir c'est une illusion
c'est en fait bien une
partie de ce que je suis humain est de
broder des appareils technologiques donc
je  irait de cette façon, je veux dire, je sais que cela
brouille la distinction entre les
bourgeons virtuels et non virtuels, je pense que c'est une
façon de gérer ce
cool, y a-t-il autre chose dont vous voulez
parler, demandez ou juste une sorte de prélude
ah eh bien je je le ferais  tiens à vous remercier pour l'
opportunité de discuter de cet article, c'était
très agréable pour moi, je l'ai vraiment apprécié
et c'est euh un environnement très agréable et euh
confortable pour discuter de ces
questions et réfléchir merci encore une fois
merci ouais super discussion et
sujets importants et  nous serons heureux de
vous reparler à tout moment d'
accord merci au revoir merci